[Music]
more poetic justice today y'all
a criminal who mugged and injured an old
lady
has suffered a horrific attack in prison
dean kenyon age 35 required extensive
surgery after another inmate poured
boiling water over his arms and legs
that's poetic justice though right whoa
you have a grandma yeah and you get
[ __ ] up don't touch those grandmas but
what is that one supporting justice part
though
that you got [ __ ] up oh i see
what's poetic about it yeah well i guess
that was what i was oh the poetic part
is that grandma's like that grandmas use
hot water all the time
like tease and stuff
yeah they're mine they're mine you wear
them they look way better those those
are steve's actually but
yeah i thought they're nice because bart
looks like a librarian
because that's a naughty librarian dude
yeah you kind of are not even but when
when steve wears it he looks like he's
on a computer a lot he also looks kind
of hot though yeah
anyways dude kenyon was in custody after
he snatched a purse
from a 79 year old woman in january
knocking her to the ground and leaving
her with life-changing injuries poetic
justice life-changing
on the ground
he grabbed just say it whenever he grew
on the ground huh but he got
life-changing injuries too so that's
poetic
oh
once you get burnt it doesn't really go
back the way you want it to no you look
like fried chicken
yeah it looks bad you look like fried i
used to call this girl fried chicken
because half of her body was covered in
burn who used to no they used to in high
school i never he switched it to a day
right when you got a ball he was like
they
did
joe is that poetic justice
not for her
so uh no you know what we should call it
jamali injustice that's what it used to
be you're changing the game on me man oh
[ __ ] i got it i kinda like that better
some of us can't partake in that then it
feels a little exclusive
it's okay i'll allow you so who called
this girl fried chicken
these guys at school oh they're like hey
you know that girl and i'm like oh yeah
she got a pretty face dude she's [ __ ]
like you know par wide part chinese and
[ __ ] oh i know who you're talking about
like oh oh he's the day and then they're
like and then they're like they call it
fried chicken fried chicken they're like
oh yeah like
her name is fried chicken and i'm like
why and they're like you ever see her
back and then she does have a burn
half of her body is burned
because when she was a kid like you know
um she was [ __ ] with the stove and
[ __ ] and then the stove the the hot
water fell on her back and it melted
she's cute though she used to hang out
alice right do you think her mom was
maybe making fried chicken because i
think that's what would be called oh no
you're
all wrong i'm going to say that oh i
mean joe
never mind see i'm not used to it yet
that's that's kentucky fried
i justice like that's [ __ ] up man
i don't know don't laugh she's still
burned no i'm laughing today okay so he
uh he had boiling water poured over his
arms and legs resulting in uh fried
chicken i mean skin grafts to his arms
and legs he has had five skin graft
operations and his mobility is to be
affected by these he's currently heavily
sedated and is in constant and searing
pain while being served mashed potatoes
and corn and uh the court her besides
for having chicken
and honey
that is good that is good the court
heard that kenyan's level of remorse is
significant yeah [ __ ] with his
lawyer describing the 35 year old as
mortified by his actions
that's how's that point justin i'm
mortified i don't know
i'm so lost in this one
fried chicken let's just bring it back
to fried chicken
if
someone
were to harm an old person or child or
whatever i think
we should do fried chicken justice like
instead of the kentucky fried chest
like let's imagine somebody sitting in a
chair right jolly bee justice we'll call
it charlie be
[Laughter]
j.r
jr
and [ __ ] jr justice jr
justice justice aquino
um
joe is such a worldly man that when he
hear when he hears about those girls
he's like captain
crunch no quicker oh it's quicker
quicker over okay they both got it
though they both got it all right
imagine a dunk tank right but a
criminal's in it it's a fried chicken
duct tape oh hot oil hot oil
and you throw [ __ ] biscuits and he's
breaded too
he's bread
he got a different [ __ ] on an egg
that's really good oh my god he's
breading other than tar and feathered
it's breaded and burned breaded and
burned up and then eaten am i right of
course see at least the skin i'd eat the
skin is this guy alive after
yeah i think the part where he has like
remorse is it shows that he's alive i
think he needs to so it has to be a
flash it has to be a flash fry that's
right yeah yeah or splash or a little
bucket a little bucket of oil oh like
instead of ice bucket challenge it's a
hot oil challenge als challenge that
like amount of pours or dips is like how
many counts of like felony or problems
double pride
yeah like that and then he'll know how
much he messed up yeah you know that was
a medieval
like technique to keep people away from
the wall so like when dudes with the
battering rams and [ __ ] they would come
oh yeah pour the oil
and then like on the what do you call it
the battle tower [ __ ] they have holes
where they can [ __ ] just dump the oil
on the bad guys it's just been egg and
powder and stuff and just bread in them
should have thrown marbles down
the old home alone they get through the
gates all these [ __ ] guys are working
oh yeah they fall on their swords too
bad home alone wasn't you know
out there they would have known they had
no idea they should've just heated up
the doorknobs
you guys need a battery just come on in
they did have doorknobs
they did
[Laughter]
yeah
big [ __ ] doorknobs bigger than your
head huge
biblical doorknob is singapore the only
country that's kind of got these cool
ways of like punishing of punishing the
citizenry place
no there's a lot uh still going on and
they're okay
yeah what's cool
uh i mean i think like back in the day
when they had that stretch board and
they tie your hands and feet and then
they stretch you oh yeah
you see the ones in the medieval ones
where they like they like bind you and
then they tickle you to death with a
feather
to death how you die of that dude like
people can yeah people can actually yeah
like imagine are you ticklish like
imagine watching you tickle them real
quick
you just try to try it i'm ticklish
stop you see how death is at his door
right now you see it in his face i'll
die pretty quick i think dude when i
first started dating nikki
is he right back at you i mean couples
do the stupid fighting thing yeah yeah
so me and nikki were doing that show me
uh i was stone cold stunning her no
he [ __ ] suplexed her
no i you know like we're [ __ ] around
or whatever and then she
she thought that maybe i was ticklish
and i was like i was like very plainly
like i'm not ticklish i am ticklish
though but but i was like if i hold this
enough in the early moments of our
relationship then she'll always think
i'm not ticklish and that'll be really
beneficial for me
so she won't turn up you don't want to
set a precedence exactly stand strong
but then unfortunately so one time i
just let it slip one time when she like
was it was like that and then i [ __ ]
giggled and she's like you're [ __ ]
ticklish
this was like this was like 10 months in
oh [ __ ] i thought i was out of the woods
i was like i'm good i'm in the free air
let your guard down it's like her
discovering a poker tell on someone else
it is man no [ __ ] weight the whole
time yep you ever do that thing though
like should you take us you can punch
her and i've never known i wouldn't do
that yeah i wouldn't do that either yeah
ever that's what you did
that's what i heard they did yeah they
if you want to do any form of abuse you
do it while you're sleeping
then it's you didn't abuse anybody you
were sleep walking
wow oh you were sleeping that's what it
was poetic
sleep hooking yeah okay you're sleeping
pouring the oil on the stove and boiling
it do your guys ladies do you guys
ladies like like when you're walking in
front of her
does she like to like credit card your
butt cheeks all the time
when you're walking in front of them on
stairs it's different how do you guys
react you guys freak out
i flinch you turn around you go guard
declines
[Laughter]
what do you do catch your hands with
your [ __ ] out i freak out like crazy she
just like just puts her finger in my ass
while we're at the grocery store and she
goes like my puppet
and then you come home
[Laughter]
and then it's clean up on aisle four
goes in i'm like
what do i do what do i do it's like
ratatouille
[ __ ] assatooi
it's not fair because she touches the
butt like whatever how many times a year
it is but like the amount of times i
touch her butt is [ __ ] unbelievable i
think the same way there i do the same
thing i feel bad i feel guilty i feel
horrible and then sometimes i let her
i'll be like all right i take her hand
like okay just do it but under my
control because when my hand's not there
she gets all crazy and then she'll jam
fingers up there so i have to guide it i
go okay this is it and i let her go up
and ba up and down my crack my butthole
is so tight though there's nothing she
could do
that's what is that i bet this one i
could do are you challenging her no
she's challenging nick she's trying i
bet i could maybe nick i bet i can't get
in between those two i feel like i asked
you before but like your like fight
training doesn't kick in like
instinctively when someone's like
honestly
no it does it does like when she tries
to tickle me i have to be very like
careful you put her to sleep
yeah dude because you're passed that
guard you know what i mean i [ __ ] i
slice right through that like i'll
restrain her and be like stop playing
stop playing because
i'm gonna freak out so that's like oh
yeah i'm a weapon i'm a [ __ ] weapon
i just throw an elbow it's out of
nowhere
well does she know how to block it nope
so you didn't you don't want to teach
her how to block just want to learn i
just i just run away dude i just get out
of there i just i just remove myself
from the situation
you guys know you guys need to be more
vulnerable with your women if she
touches your butt grab one cheek the
other cheek and spread it even more i
try i'm working my way up it just takes
time i can't be as sexually liberal as
joe and i'm so sad about it
[Laughter]
one day steve one day you open those
cheeks
[Music]
you